welcome back to new rockstars spiderman
no way home is coming this december
and right now the sky is the limit for
whatever dream casting fans want
alfred molina doc and jamie foxx electro
are returning
somehow meanwhile many are claiming
willem dafoe could return as norman
osborne green goblin
have we learned nothing from our own big
question episode warning about
unconfirmed rumors posing as news
well don't jerk that knee too hard to
that thumbnail my friends because
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest
theories for the movies that we love
emphasis on theories
this is we're in the theory land right
now uh as of this taping willem dafoe
has norman osborne coming back
is still just a mere theory but still
something we hope happens we want to
happen
and something we're going to hypothesize
about so oh by the way i'm eric boss
going to rogue with me today
is a wonderful panel including
mastertainment
mt hey what's going on everybody good to
have you back also
host of the film lost first podcast
eddie villenueva welcome
guys so good to be with y'all so be so
good to be with fellow nerds
hell yes uh also streamer extraordinaire
angelica trey
hey hey
it's good to be back good to be back
with you
and we're excited to welcome to new rock
stars actor artist and creator of the
thriller spell
barrick hardly welcome barry yeah oh
what a what a pleasure to be here i
started as a
fan and now i'm on the thing oh my god
welcome back to the thing guys look at
this panel we got
uh five of us hosting theory today
i i feel in great company i can't wait
to
have you all weigh in on this topic
because it's a party now
oh yeah one extra nerd pull up pull up a
fifth chair to this table on the end you
know because someone's gonna get bumped
by the server's elbow a few times in
this conversation that's the great thing
about that's the great thing about the
nerd table there's always room for more
that's what i'm saying
well said eddie well said well let's
dive into this spider-man no way home of
course is
confirmed to include past spidey
villains doc ah for molina and electro
jamie foxx with molina confirming his
character is gonna be the same guy from
that sam raimi spider-man 2 in 2004 and
both of these villains appeared to die
in those movies and they were in
different movie universes so
it's not really clear yet how this movie
will resurrect them and cross them over
but we know benedict cumberbatch doctor
strange will be in the film too so many
believe
a multiverse crossover is the only
logical answer
uh we have discussed this a lot on the
channel
that this has kind of led to a
speculation frenzy
that everyone now from toby maguire and
andrew garfield to charlie cox
and dane duhan are also going to return
these are all unconfirmed as of this
taping actually most have been denied by
the actors and they're really being
claimed with little to no
actual evidence by hungry hungry clickos
and the
latest rumor is that willem dafoe is
returning as norman osborne green goblin
and of all of these speculated
uh statements of possibilities that's
the one i'm actually
most excited even more than toby he
killed it
he's crazy but the issue of course is
he's another dead spidey villain really
most memorable for haunting james
franco's mirror
but we know at least stockhock and
electro will for sure be in this movie
suggesting that
we're gonna get some kind of team of
villains so my question for all of you
is who do you think is gonna be the
primary villain of spider-man no way
home and
uh maybe we should start with just this
question of could norman osborne
actually return
what would that look like that's a tough
one i mean you look at willem dafoe
and mind you as the enigmatic
green goblin in the utility maguire
series i mean he was great but
i mean let's be honest that's been
almost over about 15 16 17 years ago
it's been a while uh i i don't know if
willem dafoe was
willing to put that back on his resume
as coming back as the green goblin
that would be nice uh but i i i want to
put my money more in the arena of kind
of continuing where the first one let
off
where we see kind of a reemergence of
the vulture
would be nice to see come back into the
fray just because
he's kind of been sitting in the
background he hasn't done anything he
hasn't
we didn't hear from him in the second
film i feel like
having time worked with obviously
scorpion and i'm pretty sure getting
communicated with everything else going
on in the world
uh there has to have been something that
kind of clicked with him i i just really
want to see michael keaton back that's
really it that's that's the fullness
that's fair
we all want to see michael keaton oh
yeah he killed it in homecoming and he's
definitely coming back
i mean that morbius trailer definitely
teased like hey you know we we
around here somewhere we had a prison
you know what i'm saying we want the
keaton let's go
give us the bird man
give me batman and the batman yeah
exactly there's no coincidence
with that and the vulture okay so
just going off of of what eddie said i
definitely think
that would be really cool because if
it's potentially setting up
sinister six type stuff then that would
be
a neat addition i definitely think they
could have
maybe some sort of extra secrets up
their sleeves in terms of the villain
but for the sake of today's conversation
if they do bring in the green goblin
i think he would be more of a main
villain of course there's a lot going on
with this film because we've got wanda
here
who's got a hold of the darkhold
and is potentially messing around with
all of these different universes
so doctor strange confirmed coming
through
and trying to maybe fix some of these
universes with the multiverse and
where there's a multiverse there's a
spider verse so
potentially we could be seeing all of
these villains but i definitely think
if there is green goblin he's going to
be like the primary villain
and like going off of what eddie said
maybe it could
potentially bring in like vulture and
other villains too and setting up for
things like the sinister six
that's that's a really good point it
really is especially with the makings
already
we got two thirds are about close to
half of those people already established
in
some form or fashion in the mcu no
coincidence no coincidence i i don't
know if we're wanting paul giamatti back
as the rhino though
yeah bring him back come on i mean like
he was a great
like he's a great actor but like was he
true though i want to see like the
actual rhino suit comic accurate
just like give me a man in a rhino suit
straight up they
yeah i'd like that there you go yeah but
that's how i feel about
most of the people from from the first
two uh
movie series is like i don't know which
ones i'd want back
if i'm going to be a jerk about it uh
willem dafoe like
cool guy great actor like but does that
character belong in the mcu like
he's so big and the mco doesn't have a
lot of villains just
like screaming everyone
yeah for that matter like
i i don't want re there's like one guy
i want to come back in the whole thing
like i don't want dennis leary back like
that's a crazy energy for me
james franco no i don't want james brent
go back like martin sheen
i dig martin sheen big time uh as uncle
ben but also i'm like
streaming the west wing again so i'm
pretty good with him
i love wesley though it's a great [ __ ] i
was just thinking like the guy i do want
to come back who i do
hope is is the main villain i don't
think it'll happen
uh cause he's dead it's it's randy the
macho man savage is bone saw mcgraw like
the one character i believe like needs
to complete
there aren't that doesn't matter oh my
god death doesn't matter
it doesn't matter all of those villains
died
like they all died and we're bringing
them back in real life death doesn't
matter either
that's what they say the only the only
rule in comic books is
nobody really dies except for uncle ben
yeah but you know
randy savage is dead dead in real life
so i don't know how i mean they could
recast them but like it would be kind of
weird
no they can bring them back they're
going to find a way cgi randy savage
yeah
they have to find a way one style spend
millions of dollars
i heard the character and i just
completely just
yeah disregarded the actor okay yeah no
that's completely fair okay maybe not
but going off of what you said barrick
it's
the raimi verse is already established
in this if all of these leaks are true
with these villains so
maybe we'll get some other remy goodness
i mean yeah it's confirmed but it's like
it's so hard to understand the logic of
this even just saying multiverse it
doesn't answer the question enough for
me
is is it portals is it like a rift
from the upside down opens up in your
wall and someone comes out covered in
web goo and they're like i'm from
another reality
and the hand of god grabbed me from my
classroom well if it's dr
strange why not portals i mean it
doesn't explain
here's my thing is it doesn't explain
whether those characters are coming
to you know tom holland's universe the
tom hall and spidey universe or if
they're
going through the other universes but
the suggestion of the name no way home
implies that you know they're going to
get lost probably tom holland spidey in
these different universes and like has
to find his way back somehow because dr
strange is going to
go missing i don't know i don't know
what's gonna happen there's a lot here
i have a theory as to who the villain is
and how it's all gonna tie together
it's kind of wild so i think the villain
of this movie is going to be uh
norman osborne green goblin um well in
in the future um not in this movie i
think it's gonna be craven but in the
future it's gonna be normal osmo green
goblin but here's here's why i think of
it
because if you look at the spider-man no
way home
teaser with the marker board you can see
um
tony stark's little arc reactor on there
as well as a cube
um indicating like it's the tesseract so
i think that the
this um this new element that tony stark
made
in iron man 2 is based on tesseract
technology
which is the space stone which creates
wormholes
so where i'm going with this is this new
element that tony stark created
may play a factor in what um in
in norman osborne's spider-versey type
goals and here's why i think so
because end game introduced the concept
of time travel so now we're the
mcu now has this weird time travel space
race
going on because once one person does
something everyone's going to want to do
it
and so norman osborne of the mcu who's
like been sort of like you know
being low-key being a politician
whatever not a politician being like a
you know a rich guy he's just like all
right i want to capture that i want to
be
the next tony stark i want to you know
do time travel so he
takes this um wormhole technology well
he takes the science of the tesseract
that
um tony stark made the new element from
and he tries to create a wormhole
through space and time but he actually
just creates a wormhole
through the multiverse and you know
another version of
norman osborne's like listen up buddy um
i need you to know that spiderman's a
problem
and i need you to take care of him
because he always ruins everything
throughout the multiverse
and so he's like you know what all right
let's do that so
i think that he's gonna assemble a
sinister six through that
um technology wow i talked a lot thank
you for listening
i have a couple follow-ups so you're
saying that like we're gonna have a
different norman osborne in the mcu
who opens this gateway and on the other
end of that portal is willem dafoe
okay that's that's interesting because
that would establish the rules of
in different universes different actors
play that identity
yeah we could have a double will in the
foe situation we could have a will to
phone the mcu
and then on ren another random uh
william to phone number osborne just
being like hey look i'm you from another
universe
and sort of doing that but like it could
be another actor it could be anything
but yeah i think that um green goblin is
is coming
and it's going to be a main the main um
force in the sinister six yeah i i think
the multiverse
is most likely to be the answer but i
also think it's very possible that
sony may just take the route of these
characters have just always existed in
different forms in this universe
not meaning that there were other
spider-man before the tom holland
spider-man
but like the fact that they had jk
simmons playing j jonah jameson i think
when it comes to the villains
i think sony's just like no we're the
logic of them being a different universe
is played by those actors no one really
cares about that other than a couple
nerds on the internet
and if they didn't care that much at jk
simmons playing like an
altered version of this character even
though he's the same actor they're not
gonna care
if it's uh you know uh willem dafoe
or or alfred molina or jamie foxx
playing this villain now
um but i think once this movie comes out
everyone's gonna be like the [ __ ] are
you talking about
that doesn't make any sense uh we saw
that guy fight tobey maguire we saw that
guy
fight andrew garfield how does that make
any sense now
look look guys i think the bottom line
is we all know who the main villain is
it's bono for spider-man turn off the
dark the musical that's that's who it is
he's gonna come in and just rewrite the
whole history
i thought you were gonna say the
landlord from the rainy movies
that's the there needs to be a crossover
from that universe like i think
swiss miss ought to drop in into the new
movie
that that musical taught us all that a
freak like me needs company
and that's a bunch of freaks with
company and look at us stronger than
ever one member short of a sinister six
yeah if they want to get real wacky with
it can they potentially do like toby
maguire's spider-man as being kind of
evil like a
a switch switch switch kind of
i think you need a switch because like
if we do drop two
old spidermans into this movie isn't it
gonna feel like
i just saw this and it was better in the
one where one was a talking pig
and one uh who beat up nazis like that's
far more interesting than
going to a spider-man movie like i've
seen that so well done
and then just to see andrew garfield
drop in and like
not the camera doesn't seem all that fun
to me unless there's a spin
where like oh they are villains now or
uh yeah
play some like super essential plot i
just want to see more toby
i want to see him cry and hold pizza
it's been a long time since i've seen
toby maguire hold pizza so it's uh he's
overdue pizza time
i i think one villain that we're
overlooking if
if the charlie cox rumors are true i
mean
if you could get dinafrio kingpin in
there
like he'd be freaking great and then he
could justify some of those crossovers
though i don't know
i think that charlie cox rumors are even
harder to buy than the toby and andrew
ones are yeah
well so if they if they were to bring in
kingpin and you know
like the daredevil type storyline and
that whole universe
involved then i feel like my perception
of this movie and its narrative would
completely change and i don't know how
doctor strange would tie
in in the first place because now what i
imagine is this is a little bit more of
like a local
movie which i don't know if it would
make sense with the title like no way
home i'm still trying to figure out how
to tie this in
but it would be more of a local one
because i wouldn't mind seeing
you know a tom holland college years
like he's going and he works at the
bugle and he gets to meet gwen and like
harry
and all of that and then you have that
localized crime but
i don't know i i feel like they're
setting up for dr
strange and the multiverse of madness i
just
i feel like it's just going to get real
zany with it it's hard to know because
like yeah this is a joint production
between sony and marvel right
but it's ultimately sony they're the one
putting up most of the bill for it
um they call the shots it's mostly a
sony production that's that marvel can
kind of veto certain things on
and i don't know if marvel is gonna
trust
sony to handle
all of their huge multiverse crossovers
in their universe
and if you look at the way homecoming
and far from home played out
there were some big world-building
moments but most those stories seemed
pretty confined to peter parker yeah
there was a scroll
moment in the end of uh far from home
right and yeah there was
iron man and homecoming but like they
don't like
set up the broader implications of the
universe the way infinity war or even
guardians of the galaxy does
so it's like i think kevin feige wants
total control over these things before
he makes any
big moves yeah so i could see sony
wanting to bridge back to it's past sony
versus the way to do it with
molina and with uh fox but like
i i don't know if they're gonna bridge
too much into like
laying out the table for everything
marvel studios wants and dreams of
and that's that's if to say that's if to
say that they're actually going to use
those particular villains
as villains uh per se
i mean because the the the mindset could
also be that
they may not be coming into the path of
peter parker tom hall and peter parker
as an opposition but more as kind of
like one of the stops along the way as
they're going through these multiple
dimensions
because thinking about it a lot of these
people that they've mentioned so far
like alfred molina
uh jamie foxx's electro a lot of these
villains
have a very unique heart turn in their
films
and possibly just saying possibly what
if the opportunity here is is that
right before that heart turn kind of
happens in those films
they make kind of an instance you know
take for disbelief that peter parker
makes a stop somewhere in that universe
and it says something or does something
that kind of helps that
heel turn if you will to become better
which makes the ending happen as it
happens in the films
um you know maybe even like an
understanding from alfred molina
or you know something with jamie foxx's
electro who knows but
something along those lines where it's
not so much they're there as opposition
against the tom holland peter parker
but they're probably in the midst of
what's going on currently with their own
peter parker and that's just kind of a
stop along the way
i love that i like that explanation a
lot eddie that makes uh and that's kind
of what i want
these crossovers to be are limited you
know i i want this ultimately to be
peter parker's story
uh and i do want to see these cameos and
crossovers just to kind of like blow our
minds
but i want it in small doses you know we
don't need them to play
active major roles in all three acts of
the movie you know exactly so who's the
main villain
so the main villain right that's the
question we are the fans
i went into this wanting it to be a
green goblin and i still kind of do
because i love willem dafoe and the guy
can play
insane camp better than anybody and he
feels like the only one who can like
make this make sense
yeah however i'm gonna award one of you
a point
and i think i gotta give the point to
angelica because i think toby maguire
whatever version of peter parker he's
playing or if it's uncle ben or whatever
character he plays
i think would be a really cool villain
yes
toby
give us a chance to see toby again in
the movie like this and give him a
chance to like sneak in
little winks like have him say i'm gonna
put some dirt in your eye or whatever it
is
do like a you know a little like dancy
walk down the sidewalk
oh my god if all three of them did a
dance in the
in a movie that would be amazing yeah
gift material honestly yep all right
we're gonna move on a quick shout out to
our merch
which you can find at
newrockstarsmerch.com we got a whole
bunch of great t-shirt designs and
hoodies water bottles
all stuff you need to do authentic new
rock starts cosplay
you can find it all over at uh new
yorkers merch.com
we want to thank some friends to help us
make this episode uh starting with our
friends at bespoke post
so uh this spring as you get back
outdoors to explore take bespoke post on
all of your adventures with a new lineup
of essential box of awesome collections
for guys guaranteed to upgrade your life
they've got a box with fancy handmade
sunglasses leather carrying case
and microfiber cloth they have another
box with everything you need to build an
herb garden
minty no matter what you're into box of
awesome has you covered from style and
grooming goods to bar wear cooking tools
and outdoor gear box of awesomeness
collections for every part of your life
and to get started take the quiz at box
of awesome.com your answers will help
them pick the right box of awesome for
you
they release new boxes every month
across a ton of different categories
it's free to sign up and you can skip a
month or cancel anytime each box
only costs 45 bucks but has over 70
dollars worth of gear inside
get 20 off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code rogue at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code rogue for
20 off your first box we also want to
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
episode so our friends at blue chew have
a unique online service that delivers
these same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door
in a discrete package you sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you receive your
prescription within days the licensed
medical providers work with you to find
the right ingredient in strength and if
you hate swallowing pills good news blue
chew is chewable
just like it says in the name so if you
could benefit from extra confidence when
it's time to perform visit bluetooth.com
for more details and important safety
information and we got a special deal
for our audience try bluetooth free when
you use our promo code rogue
checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
rogue to receive your first
month for free and we thank bluetooth
for sponsoring this episode
rogue theory is also sponsored by better
health many of us have gone through
periods where something that was
interfering with our happiness and
preventing us from achieving our goals
in times like that better help is there
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
but it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it is professional counseling done
securely online available worldwide
there is a broad range of expertise
available uh which
may not be locally available in many
areas
and you can schedule weekly video or
phone sessions so you won't ever have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
before an appointment better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help wants you to start
living a happier life today visit
betterhelp.com
rogue that's better h-e-l-p and join the
over 1 million people who have taken
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better help that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
special offer for rogue theory audience
get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
rogue
all right let's move on to our second
topic quantum mania
a word we've been hearing a lot since
december 2020
and i'm obsessed with it it's gonna be
the title of ant-man the wasp quantum
mania the third movie of that franchise
it's gonna be coming the year after next
right uh and director peyton reed
announced that they've begun production
this week with this tweet confirming
that they're using
the volume that's that 360 degree led
screen backdrop that they use in the
mandalorian it's like super vivid
backdrop technology and they can create
any setting they want even fantastical
ones but
the word quantum mania what the hell
does that mean
obviously it seems connected with the
quantum realm which is where
so much of the second movie explored
actually in tuesday's video i um
theorized that maybe quantum mania could
be the name of that
quantum realm city that was hidden in
the background of the second movie
that could be what quantum mania is but
i'm curious from you
folks what do you think quantum media
means i think
that it's probably just an indicator
that they're just gonna go on a crazy
quantum adventure
um like throughout time and like you
know maybe elements from different
time periods will pop up in like you
know in the modern times or like you
know just things are just
just going awry and like maybe scott and
the gang have to figure out what's going
on
but i also had a weird theory today that
like
maybe like quantum mania the word
quantum mania is
you know in response to ant-man's
attempts to rename himself
because like you know in the ant-man
films in an end game he's basically
been in the quantum realm so i feel like
he wants to call himself quantum man
instead of ant-man
so like you know quantum man together is
quantimania
i wouldn't want to be called ant-man
realistically because it doesn't sound
cool
true true very true i think i think what
we're going to get is we're going to get
kind of a
a slight if you will kind of upset and
jealous hank pym if you will
to seeing as you had uh you had bruce
banner and all them try to work with the
quantum realm and everything
with end game trying to figure it out
and him kind of saying like no you don't
know anything about it let me take that
and i'm gonna fix it him and janet
kind of work towards figuring out a more
sleeker way
of traveling the quantum realm which
kind of jump starts the whole
ant-man and possibly him and hope hope
and
going through the quantum realm together
and kind of traveling a little bit more
in a
in a sleeker more efficient style if you
will and i believe visiting that
uh quantum city that was kind of through
one of the up one of the films
all right i'm going to take a stab at
this and it it's it's going to be wrong
but
okay but i have i think i have a wrong
i think i have a good theory that will a
a right theory that'll lead
me to be wrong okay so when doctor
strange and infinity war
he what's the number he said like i went
to 14 million other
uh universes yeah yeah there was only
one
that that thanos didn't win which means
then all those other universes
thanos killed everybody and they like
stayed they stayed dead right or snapped
away
which means that like oh in their future
they're going to have lots of resources
because thanos is playing work
but in our universe because thanos
didn't win
like we're continuing to use all our
resources at a rapid pace which means in
the future
there's not going to be any and i think
like somebody from the deep future
can look around at all the other
universes and figure out like oh
we need to make that happen on our earth
or else there's no future for mankind so
i think like
the movie could be like king the
conqueror coming back
and trying to finish thanos job here's
where
it gets really good and wrong is that um
i think then he sends doctor strange
like into all the other universes
and makes him fight all the other
universes and
wrestle them in a bit like wrestlemania
yeah do you like how i landed that
theory
i did not see that coming that would be
nuts it's a little royal
crazy but yeah hell yeah wrestlemania
okay so this theory is a little wacky as
well
hey get wacky angelica get wet wacky
okay
i'm getting crazy all right so previous
so earlier
uh i know the the ant-man production
supposedly had a
casting call for like a a young girl who
like they wanted her to sing and dance
right and i think she was supposed to be
they set it up like she was going to be
maybe a more
major character or important character
so i'm thinking what if this is a way to
tie in
x-men i've been trying to bring the
x-men
in with my theories for so long one of
them's gotta strike gold so
one of them has to i'm gonna keep
throwing them out until it happens
but um what if they what if
it is a reference to
in history with like musical idols
like listamania beetlemania
right what if this is quantimania
tying in the quantum realm but also
that concept and this is actually going
to be the dazzler
or just dazzler yeah it was previously
like a
like a disco idol but maybe she'll be a
different iteration like like a pop star
or something
i love that quite the rogue theory
okay let's go let's go you know you know
let me help you tie in the x-men because
like this is a thing about
time travel what about cable you know
cable's whole deal
is time travel yeah so like you know
maybe yeah we might see
cable at some point um during these you
know time travel shenanigans either in
loki or in here we're at ant-man three
i feel like dazzler would tie in so well
because of the the comedic flavor that
they have to so many of the ant-man
movies
i just want to see it i think at this
point we're all owed
a dazzler in this movie
but the point i'm going to award will go
to barrick because i think
a wrestlemania right here mania i
picture a brawl
a huge crossover with a bunch of
warriors and that's the one i want
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful dream
isn't it yes beautiful
doctor strange comes down with the power
elbow
[Laughter]
all right it's still i think anyone's
game because we got a couple rogue
questions we're gonna go into here
first off uh this news that the writers
for the loki series have cited
teletubbies as an inspiration
for the show uh so i want to know what
other show for
babies might have inspired some other
marvel
uh studios movie or show i mean
everybody knows that uh
blue's clues inspired jessica jones so
uh we don't even say that
i feel like there are some parallels
there burt and ernie had real
falcon and winter soldier vibes to me
uh-huh yeah i could see that
i mean are we going to talk little bear
inspired luke cage
i mean just saying
[Laughter]
dude i freaking love little bear growing
up man great show
nice classical music the only thing i
could think of is muppet babies and that
in no way applies to anything
i can't think of another baby shows yeah
baby shows right now because i know
blue's clues teletubby freaked me out
because they had that
baby son the baby sun scared the crap
out of me
so i thought we were gonna say like loki
was gonna have a baby son or something
for a second there i was getting worried
i mean thomas the tank engine uh showed
up in ant-man
so there's a true parallel there yeah
what about like
uh can we count a little bit of an older
show like
magic school bus but with ant-man
kind of like they shrink that bus down
yeah
yeah i think that's there i i see that i
see that i mean
you know wanda vision was inspired by
reading rainbow with the dark hole which
is great
true uh-huh very true levar burton is
satanic we got it cool
yes he's uh the secret villain
i think sid and marty croft is a real
like guardians of the galaxy kind of
like
by the flashy colors and the weird
characters yeah
i see that too i think all of these if
you uh just keep reaching a bit further
back you can find uh baby shows and all
of these things
because they inspired us but uh i'm
gonna give the point to blue's clues to
jessica jones mt because i think
thank you yeah i'm just reciting history
man i'm just telling you the facts you
know i read it on wikipedia which means
it's true
it's true all right we have another
question here an upcoming discovery show
called otter dynasty is being described
in marketing materials as
game of thrones with otters so
what is the most game of thrones thing
and otter could do
toss a small child out the window be a
strong honor
like i don't know maybe like ride a
whale do otters do that maybe ride a
whale like a dragon
the cool otters do yeah the cool ones
anyway
they could set up a big wedding with the
beavers down the creek
and then and kill them all at the
reception
oh that's right so graphic
the red wedding i'll never forget that
oh my god
oh like a parallel between polar bears
and the white walkers
or something like the polar bears come
and try to try to tell those stories
okay it's very jarring to switch from
marvel
to game of thrones so quickly to go like
oh
do i make an incest joke at this point
like
i think you do yeah i mean every time
you talk about game of thrones the
incest joke is there
right it's a cornerstone of that program
apparently yeah well i'm going to give
the point to barrick for uh otter
versus beaver red wedding i think it's
right there and i need to see it happen
oh my god the wedding's in game of
thrones epic
you can't trust me amazing like your
life has changed after those
you're slightly traumatized well i think
if my math is correct that makes barrick
our winner
what do i get well well done barrick
thank you for coming on the show
and along with all of our guests mt
eddie and angelica
follow all of them on their social media
support their projects i have four very
talented people in front of me who are
working on great
yes and follow eric on social media as
well he's great now
i'll probably be in a bad mood if you
try to tweet me i tend to be i need to
just unplug from twitter i think right
now but hey follow if you want
hey support this channel by checking out
uh one of our many great merch options
at newarkstarsmerch.com follow new
rockstars on social media subscribe here
on youtube and we will see you next time
goodbye everybody
[Music]
you